her and Sam collect a bowl of worms from
the spot and she instructs him to stay
inside while she takes the bowl into the
basement where the babadook is locked up
and seemingly feeds him using the bowl
of worms the short film monster has a
similar ending where the mother
periodically feeds the monster a glass
of milk to keep it satiated so what is
the significance of the switch to worms
as the snack of choice for the Baba duck
I think it has to do with the journey
that Amelia has gone through to reach
this point during the climax no not that
climax she was so far gone that she
killed her dog and nearly her son if you
look closely the worms are picked right
from above the dog's gravite so she
seems to be using them as a motivation
to keep her grief in check by taking
some time to acknowledge it every now
and then so it doesn't grow and fester
into a monster that she cannot control
Amelia never fully defeats the Baba duck
but this is a good first step towards
taking some of its power and making it
more manageable the film as a whole
plays as a very lonely isolating
experience because only her and the sun
encounter it